[Music]
las vegas firefighters are investigating
a huge early morning fire a lightning
supply a lighting supply business i
should say went up in flames near sahara
and maryland parkway clogging traffic
and filling the sky with smoke bianca
holmen reports
well the fire is mostly out you can see
there is a crew still here on scene
making sure that there are no hot spots
it was just before 4 tuesday morning
parking enforcement officers working in
the area of sahara and maryland parkway
noticed smoke three fire departments
responded to the fire of the two-story
statewide lighting center building a
lighting production and fixture company
we got inside we found a dumpster
that was on fire plus there was some
pallet shipping pallets
that was added to the fuel as crews
worked to contain the fire there was
concern that the roof could collapse
more than 60 firefighters fought the
blaze from the outside ensuring the fire
did not spread to surrounding buildings
what could be the cause i don't have any
idea he says it was just business as
usual when they closed up
everything appeared to be fine
so investigators are still trying to
determine the cause of this fire that
started here at the statewide lighting
center and of course no word yet on the
cost of damages we will keep you all
updated online bianca holmen live local
now